I tried standing up to my dad it was  actually just through Tech so I really  wasn't even they wouldn't even asked to  hit it with all caps but I learned the  word ignorant and I was like that's my  dad he was antagonizing my mom this was  like during like divorce which it's  actually really heated it's like yeah  yeah yeah perfect he was like so I text  my Dad we're at the mall and I was like  yo Pops leave mom alone you're being  ignorant right yeah this was grown up  yeah yeah upset he called me right away  and he goes where you at and I'm like  I'm at the mall he's like I'll pull up  over there right now do you want to talk  to me like an adult like we can go like  run me my fade and I was like I was just  saying that you have to like leave mom  alone like most try to like like get his  shoes and you're I was kind of like mad  at like my mom a little bit and I was  like I stood up for you all right I  tried it and you made me look ignorant